it's coming III 2015 baby with the
year's biggest video game event right
around the corner it's that time again
to put on your best and gets light for
the hottest upcoming games but you
already knew that the real question is
how the heck are you gonna watch it all
when III 2015 kicks off look no further
because gamespot will be covering all of
III s greatest moments we're talking the
latest news on upcoming titles brand new
hardware interviews with the biggest
developers and sweet gameplay from the
tastiest games that III has to offer
take a seat over at gamespot.com where
we are serving all of III s major press
conferences along with our pre-show
expectations and post-show in-depth
breakdowns we'll start you off with
Bethesda's conference on sunday june
14th at 630pm pacific the next day some
monday morning microsoft at nine a.m.
pacific followed by EA and ubisoft
conferences and then finishing the night
with sony's conference at six pm and
finally tuesday with nintendo 9 a.m.
pacific followed by square enix and pc
gaming show when the e3 show floor opens
up on tuesday the game spa main stage
we'll be there streaming live gameplay
demos and developer interviews that's
Tuesday 1 p.m. pacific and wednesday and
thursday starting at 11am oh what's that
you want more kind of funny partners
with gamespot bringing you a second III
exclusive stream where you'll catch Greg
call an end the gang interview
celebrities preview games and much more
that's too III streams all week watch us
live at gamespot.com / III or for the
very first time on youtube.com slash
gamespot starting sunday june 14th at
six-thirty p.m. pacific we'll see you
then
you